this is a super fragmented environment
right now when every insurance company
is trying to do her own thing
and try to propose its own model and
it's not unified and it's not
tapping into the same you know data
feeds and incentives
and it's so fragmented there's there's
no way something
meaningful can happen
[Music]
auron effect thank you so much for
joining me on 20 minute leaders how are
you
all right good michael thanks for having
me man good to see you so so
two really interesting things to start
off first of all you're in wyoming
right even though you're based out of
san francisco
yeah yeah what is that i started with
after corona started uh
uh my wife and i decided to just you
know take take this journey and start
working remotely from
you know multiple places and you know
it's i've been living in the us for
seven years now and it's the first time
actually experiencing it
from the ground itself instead of from
the air
uh you know those little uh you know
20-minute trips from the airport
into a meeting back to the airport it's
for the first time i can experience the
nature and
jackson home wyoming was one of the more
attractive destinations for
you know for us to spend some time so
trying to work from the road now and
it's
you know amazing i love it i love it so
so just as fascinating as that is you
also do
iron mans right yearly
yeah you're trying trying to trying to
keep in um
you know mental shape and uh it comes it
comes with a physical
it comes with a physical requirement so
i i try to
um there originally started to do it for
you know just just for the challenge but
over the time it'd been like a mental
therapy
and a great travel destination thing so
you know been in new zealand been in
mexico
places i would i would i wouldn't go
otherwise if i had to hannah
you know anything unbelievable so you
know
for a lot of people doing these iron
mans are almost a full-time job because
of how intense they are
so just for just for the ear tell me a
little bit about
what is the distance for the running
cycling and
for the swimming portions yeah when the
folks are doing it full-time job
actually good athletes i'm not
considering myself a good athlete i just
i just do it for the sport
um so the distances would be uh you know
uh a 3.8 kilometer swim followed by a
180 kilometer bike ride
uh and with a with a marathon
uh finish so it's uh it's pretty it's
pretty intense
it sounds it sounds very very intense
and i'm sure that just as intense as the
iron man experiences
running a startup in the in the health
space and medtech space
is just as intensive so tell me a little
bit about about what
vim is the company that you're currently
running
yeah sure so so vim is something we
started back in 2015
um you know maybe maybe a year a year
longer if you consider the time it takes
to plan
and to get to get ready to get a company
funded and get off the ground
um vim is a operating system
for healthcare networks so you know we
operate solely in the united states
which is a story by itself how we got
here and how we started this thing here
in the u.s
i mean a bunch of israelis but uh think
about think about it this way in israel
we have you know two or three large hmos
health maintenance organizations like
maccabi little meat and so on and so
forth
similar to kaiser maybe here in the u.s
fully integrated
payer and medical provider are part of
the same entity
so full alignment of interest everything
is very streamlined
physician would like to see you to
prevent
costs from happening in the us it's kind
of different the system here was
established as a
fee for service system so it's what you
would
maybe know from a world of lawyers or
accountants you know people that will
bill you
by the hour time and material right so
physicians here actually have the wrong
incentive
in my opinion which is you know treat
you when you're sick
there is there's a lack of incentive of
keeping you healthy there's an incentive
to render
more care when you're getting sick this
also
is driven because of this separation or
the institutional separation between the
payer and the provider so you have
insurance companies on one end
you know the healthcare cigna and so on
and so forth and you have medical
providers
in your case you're probably very
familiar with stanford sutter health
and all those guys um so basically this
separation between
church and state is actually not good in
health care
uh and this misalignment of incentive
given that physicians actually charging
on a fee for service basis hence
they render more care they're getting
paid more and the insurance companies
would like to get you know to pay less
you know to maintain profitability and
that inherent conflict of interest
combined with it fragmentation is is a
huge
problem resulting in this almost four
trillion dollar
cost which is you know three times more
per capita than any other oecd country
so what vin does in all this by the way
you know while we're saying this you
know you you're we
i understand the magnitude of what
you're saying but and and while you're
talking about this all i'm thinking
about is
you know that then you have millions of
americans at the end of the day through
all of this
you know misalignment and through all
this disincentives that
they were introducing into the into the
economy we have millions of americans
that just don't have proper health
benefits and they don't get taken care
of when they need they get sick when
they don't need to get sick and when
they do get sick they can't pay the
bills
and so obviously you know on one hand a
lot of people are going out and they're
solving these you know trillion dollar
problems that
of misalignment in the economy but what
you're doing here even more than that
you're
actually you know working on improving
people's lives which
you know a lot of different not not
every startup can come and say that
you're directly impacting
whether a person perhaps lives or not or
gets to get treatment
when they do get sick so i think so so
that's just to put in perspective
it's a huge problem i believe more than
half of americans don't have
four hundred dollars in the bank account
to pay in in the case of emergency
and so you know it's even greater when
we when we're it's a fee for
fee for service uh type of model but
sorry go ahead
no i appreciate you mentioning this you
know it's it's easy to forget
sometimes that that we're doing
something that is very special and
helpful for people and
you know myself and the company in
particular are very driven people and
we're doing it first and foremost to
make make a difference not for
you know economical reasons or you know
we truly believe there is a huge
financial opportunity side by side with
fixing the system just by taking
access cost out of the system yeah so
it's it's incredible
um you know and you mentioned 50 of
americans have
less than you know 400 or less available
cash in their account at any given time
take this into consideration with the
huge
deductibles that people need to pay
before their insurance even kicks in
because you know during the tap the past
15 years there was a huge shift
to cost to the patients right so
insurance companies would just
be you know puzzled of how they're going
to pay those bills they say let's
prevent
people from using the healthcare in the
first place by shifting more costs and
making them more responsible
so they still being opportunistic so the
average family deductible
is now 3 500 bucks
for a year right per year and with 400
bucks for 50
of americans it means no access to
health care so
i mean look we can do everything we want
right so veeam had to focus on one area
where we can make it
actually make a difference so what we've
been focusing on the past five years is
actually building this
connectivity tissue between
insurance companies and physicians now
physicians
a physician's not a physician so you
have like maybe a thousand different
ea we call them ehrs electronic health
records or electronic medical records
you know those
old operating systems that sit on those
provider offices
and maintain the data and help to
prescribe
drugs and so on and so forth and
obviously billing which is the main
function of those systems and those
systems don't talk with each other and
they don't have an insurance company so
we make them well talk
and and enable ease of access to data
and ease of transfer of data
and what we believe this is going to
become we believe it's going to become
the
operating system of the network of
healthcare
and thus become the uh the groundwork or
the infrastructure
for value-based care what is value-based
care it's a
it's a world where incentives are
aligned between insurance companies and
physicians
so doctors are rendering care in order
to get you healthier
and they're actually enjoying the
downstream cost savings of your health
that's what they actually monetize not
the individual service so think about a
physician who
is incentivized to render better care
and for your long-term benefit and
keeping healthy
that's how she is actually making money
downstream not from rendering more care
but by rendering less care and to
actually make this happen you need
connectivity you need data to flow
you need you need incentives to flow and
that's what vim does vm is building this
operating system to enable value-based
care
and and we are very passionate about it
so so i'm i'm deeply curious about
about where you're saying so i need
another explanation here just to make
sure i fully understand so
sure how how do you change the alignment
so that a physician
doesn't doesn't get the value from
the service but gets a value from the
patient's well-being
how does that work i understand the
connectivity between the systems and the
fact that you need
some sort of operating system to to
handle all that communication across the
board
but how does that change the incentive
of the physician versus the insurance
company
because today the swiping the credit
card happens
at the time of the ailment right
yeah absolutely it's a really good
question michael so
i think that the rule of thumb is is in
one word is
capitation um if if you think about a
a doctor in israel or australia or you
know in the uk
whatever single-payer system you can
think about they're getting they're
getting a salary
and that salary is adjusted in
accordance with the number of patients
they see
so think about moving to a similar model
where the
primary care physician the gp the person
who managing your federal health
she's making a pmpm per member per month
fee
let's say she's making uh you know 600
bucks per month
for that patient's health right if it's
an older older patient let's say so they
consume more care if it's a younger
patient maybe
250 you know 300 bucks a month for that
patient's care
right so she's getting that and she is
responsible
for the total cost of care of that
patient
so from now on she becomes like a mini
insurance company
and and on the back end you have
infrastructure supporting stop-loss and
you know other things you guys may be
familiar in your you know other day job
that you know you guys are
thinking about all day right how do you
how do you insure the
insurance companies right and so on and
so forth but but assuming she has this
infrastructure behind her
um she's basically able to be uh
uh you know rendering more care to
prevent
downstream costs and and and she's fully
incentivized to do so because she's
getting the pmpm and it's kind of uh
by the way it's amazing because think
about coronavirus
those physicians been struggling with
having office visits and people come to
them
they've been losing most of their
business at the first months of
coronavirus because people didn't show
up didn't go to
to see the doctor if the doctor gets
paid pm pm
it's getting paid what whatever happens
right so then you see this huge
uh willingness of doctors to switch the
model into a pmp and capitated model
um you know so that that's an amazing
thing that happened in the past year so
that's what we also see a
big growth for our opportunity and then
you have specialists
the specialists are not primary care
physicians they don't
need to think about people's total
health they need to think about
specific condition and procedures right
to render and so there's a different
type of capitation
that may happening for specialists i i
think about it as bundle payments so
instead of uh let's say uh someone is
giving birth
and seeing a you know 300 page bill with
you know 3 000 line items that say you
know that breaks down the anesthesia
and the uh hospitalization and the
consultations and the mris and the ct
scans and
the ultrasounds and whatever you happens
in that specific
episode instead you have a you have a
surgeon who would say
i'm gonna do this delivery in thirty
thousand dollars whatever happens
happens
and i'm responsible for total cost of
care for that episode
so if you kept the pcp the primary care
the gp
on a per month per member per month
basis and you kept the specialist on an
episode basis
you can really form a marketplace right
of value-based care you stop paying for
services you're paying for people's
health
by incentivizing you in there on a per
service basis
capped or on a per member per month
basis
capped you incentivize the individuals
to just do what what's good for the
system and i i believe you see
actually i actually believe it's the and
that's a longer conversation than 20
minutes but
i believe it's actually the answer for
other health systems
like israel and the uk and australia
where
the the the the single-payer system is
actually becoming is bankrupting because
of over demand
for private services but so i actually
think this can solve other
western war problems if you can actually
build it right
around how do you get to educate a new
market
in health and creating a new economy
between you know customer patient doctor
relationship and
insurance that whole triangle you know
this is something that the us has been
dealing it with for many years obama
obviously put it at his
at the forefront of what the forefront
of his campaign
this idea of how do we provide
accessible health care uh we've seen the
the the disastrous rollout of obamacare
very unfortunately because i think it
served it served a fantastic purpose of
fundamentally allowing people access to
healthcare which and you're doing
you're doing that you're giving that
same access but in a different and
perhaps even more meaningful way what
leads you to go and create this whole
new economy a new marketplace for
doctors for physicians insurance
companies and patients
yeah i think this is a two great
question so the first question maybe
i'll
start with answering this like what's
different in what we do
in inter because it's obviously the
approach i'm presenting is not my idea
it's it's
you know people been thinking about it
for 50 years now but
i think there's something different in
what we do over what we've done before
and the second question is like
why are we why are we doing it why we
approach this problem and
what kind of motivated so let me answer
the first question
first so um you know i mean
every physician in the united states
is on average it's contracted with
you know one large federal insurance
usually medicare
uh usually responsible for 50 of my
business as a doctor
and then another 20 or so insurance
companies
commercial insurance companies some of
them are seeing medicare advantage some
of them seeing you know
commercial population like large
employers whatever
this is a super fragmented environment
right now when every insurance company
is trying to do her own thing
and try to propose its own model and
it's not unified and it's not
tapping into the same you know data
feeds and incentives
and it's so fragmented there's there's
no way something
meaningful can happen and the doctor's
not adopting
those offerings because they only apply
for a small subset
of their patients what vim does is that
we aggregate
those insurance companies and we proud
to have to serve
the largest insurance companies in the
united states so think about anthem
united healthcare those two companies
alone have almost 100 million americans
covered under them right and you're
probably familiar with both
um so and we cover additional ones so i
think as an aggregator of insurance
companies
we're actually able to represent a
bigger portion of membership and
talk with physicians in a way that it
more appeals to them
to to really change behavior and alter
their incentives and so on and so forth
um as per the second question is i guess
it's a more it's a more difficult
question
what led us to start us so i i can
personally speak about myself my
co-founders can tell their own story
el nasa uh you know will be delighted to
to be in your show but
uh my personal story is just frost yeah
just frustration pure frustration from
my own personal
career and and where i was you know i
was i was actually very much enjoying
uh my time in the military i fell on
contributing i felt like i'm making a
difference
and then uh you know when i started to
become an entrepreneur
basically i never really worked for a
company i always try to start my own
thing and i
i think the two main companies that was
involved one is you know
in the telecommunications space selling
to large mobile operators and the other
one is in a gaming space selling to big
gambling uh
you know online gaming companies and not
to discount any of the
the values that those two you know two
areas are driving for the world
i haven't filled i haven't i haven't
felt fulfilled
and driven doing those things i i felt
like um
you know the economical impact in on my
personal life
uh was was pretty much gone after i made
you know i would say a little a little
pocket of change that i could you know
uh afford to pay rent and maybe some
some more and and i felt like
that's not really making any more
difference for me i'm trying to
really think about something will make a
difference and and the first thing it
wasn't healthcare the first thing was
i want to start a business with them
with mechanics
that i'll be passionate about and i put
a spreadsheet and i said this
little exercise you know if i could
start you know any type of company 10
years ago what i would start in
the names on the spreadsheet where
amazon and uber and airbnb and
you know it wasn't google it wasn't
apple it wasn't any of these right and i
was thinking
what is the common denominator and i
started marketplaces is what i'm really
passionate about i started reading
everything
about marketplace including the
everything store which is the amazon
early
book that you know really inspired a lot
of what you see in vim
from my standpoint and so you know
as a as a frustrated uh builder with a
hammer looking for a nail i was looking
for my marketplace to be built and
obamacare was starting to emerge back in
and and it it looked such a natural uh
natural place for me to to to try
something right so it's like
huge variation of cost with no with no
difference in quality
it's like retail 25 years ago right
i mean it's it's just amazing
opportunity
and cost and quality variation in health
care is the biggest
disparity in in the world everything
else in the world i mean u.s healthcare
is the most
uh you know the biggest market with
variation
that you can ever imagine so i thought
it's a great opportunity and and i
i didn't know anything about healthcare
back then i don't think i know too much
today but i i think i know a little bit
more and
i feel i feel very lucky to to stumble
upon
this amazing opportunity and industry
and people and
uh it's been it's been fun i think it's
it's fascinating and it's inspiring for
me to hear about about the shift in you
and and
and this sort of owners self
responsibility that he took over your
own
contentness happiness and satisfaction
and fulfillment right
i mean i believe that they've done
multiple studies on happiness levels and
satisfaction levels of people
and messiah and multiple levels of
satisfaction and fulfillment of people
and they found that there is the
as you approach i believe 80 or 90 000 a
month
a year's salary it's actually like a
logarithmic curve right your happiness
shoots up as you are able to feed your
family
and pay your rent but then as you reach
that 80 90 100
000 it starts leveling out and then the
extra money doesn't actually make
us a difference in fulfillment and and
that's where you go and you and you find
your passion and i just love that
aaron thank you so much for for being on
the show thank you for being so generous
with your time this was
inspiring for me and it's inspiring me
and hopefully my friends as well who are
listening to this to go and tackle these
big big problems
that are both very economical for a
startup but also just
a huge impact on people's lives but
before we go i have to ask you the most
important question
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself
wow it's uh and the hardest question
good question
yeah um well you know i think
the the first one is uh the first one is
easy uh
i think i'm pretty driven you just
describe why and i think it's a really
good description i'm really not
motivated by money i'm motivated by
impact
um i think i i rediscovered myself you
know i'm 30 i'm 38 now so rediscover
myself in the age of 30.
uh the second one is um
fortunately or unfortunately i'm pretty
optimistic so you know
need to try and see the horizon the full
picture
and what's what's gonna happen and try
to believe in this and
and try to be part of that uh i am truly
optimistic the u.s healthcare system is
going to change because
uh if it's not going to change uh you
know we're going to have a
20 gdp problem kind of problem you know
emerging in the next couple of years
it's ridiculous right so uh something
need to change so
hopefully to be in the right side of the
change uh the third one is pretty
tactical i think
um i think i'm pretty decisive um
so i mean there is a unlimited you know
number of
literature pages you know articles
people you can speak within this
industry and
uh and it's not never gonna be enough
and i think just
me coming from a place of zero knowledge
don't know what i don't know uh you know
alongside my co-founders
and and you know we try to make make a
difference in this industry decisiveness
is a really important
feature and and uh i think those three
maybe describe me at least
at least in 2020 or in the past you know
seven years
they describe it pretty well so i love
it ron
thank you very much enjoy the rest of
your time in in
wyoming thank you for making an impact
and a lot of people thanks guys and stay
safe and stay healthy
you too michael thanks man